so the president just signed a
bipartisan safer community act in
reaction to the events the tragic events
that took place in uvalde but the
interesting thing is when you break down
the act we'll get into it none of it
would have prevented the shooter from
doing what he did in uvalde so why are
we thinking like we finally solved the
solution so i said listen team let's
come up with some data because people
lie numbers don't let's look at the data
let's look at some stats will we find
one stat that will say here's what will
tell us a big part of the story because
some of the stuff they can do maybe it
would have prevented one percent of mass
shooting maybe three percent maybe five
percent but we're looking at what could
have prevented ninety percent of the
mass shooting so here's what we're going
to look at timeline of gun control in
u.s what the average american gun owner
looks like highest gun owning state
lowest going on in gun owning state
number of guns purchased last year gun
ownership by firearm type what solutions
work and what solutions don't so let's
get right into it
so let's take a look at what the average
american gun owner looks like in america
we have the most guns per capita roughly
400 million guns we own which is like
120 and a half per hundred but here's
what it looks like
74 percent of the time it's a male 82
percent white 31 percent married 40 have
children 44 of them live in the south
30 percent of the time they're between
50 to 64 years old lives in a suburban
area 45 percent of the time 28 percent
of them have a college degree 48 of them
are politically independent 51 percent
of them are republican 48 own guns for
protection 32 on it for hunting
79 believe owning a gun makes them safer
and 79 percent of them are in favor of
background checks for private and gun
show sales so now that we know the
proponents of gun control and the
opponents of gun control and we know the
profile of what a gun owner looks like
let's see the timeline of gun control in
america 1791 the bill of rights
including the second amendment gains
final ratification the second amendment
breeds a well-regulated militia being
necessary to the security of a free
state the right of the people to keep
and bear arms shall not be infringed
1837 georgia passes a law banning
handguns the laws ruled unconstitutional
by the supreme court and is thrown out
1865 in a reaction to emancipation
several southern states adopt black
codes which among other things forbid
black persons from possessing firearms
1871 the nras organized around its
primary goal of improving american
civilians marksmanship in preparation
for war
1934 the national firearms act of 1934
regulating the manufacture sale and
possession of fully automatic firearms
like submachine guns is approved by
congress 1938 the federal firearms act
of 1938 places the first limitation on
selling ordinary firearms persons
selling guns are required to obtain a
firearms license at an annual cost of a
dollar and to maintain records of the
name and address and address of persons
to whom firearms are sold gun sales to
persons convicted of felonies were
prohibited 1968 the gun control act of
1968 is enacted for the purpose of
keeping firearms out of the hands of
those not guilty entitled to possess
them because of age criminal background
or incompetence 1972 atf is created
listing as part of its mission the
control of illegal use and sale of
firearms and the enforcement of federal
firearm laws the atf issues firearm
license and conducts firearms license
qualifications and compliance
inspections 1997 the us supreme court in
the case of prince versus the united
states declares the background check
requirement of the brady handgun
violence prevention act
unconstitutional florida supreme court
upholds the jury's 11.5 million verdict
against kmart for selling a gun to an
intoxicated man who used the gun to
shoot his estranged girlfriend november
12 1998 chicago files a 433 million suit
against local gun dealers
and makers alleging that over supplying
local markets provided guns to criminals
april 20 1999 at columbine high school
near denver student eric harris and
dylan klebold shoot and kill 12 other
students and a teacher and wound 24
others before killing themselves the
attack renews debate on the need for
more restrictive gun control may 28 1999
exactly a month later by a 5150 vote
with a tiebreaker vote cast by vice
president al gore the u.s senate passes
a bill requiring trigger locks on all
newly manufactured handguns and
extending waiting period and background
check requirement to sales of firearms
at gun shows february 2010 a federal law
signed by president barack obama took
effect allowing
licensed gun owners to bring firearms
into national parks and wildlife refuges
as long as they are allowed by state law
june 12 2016 president obama again calls
on congress to enact or renew a law
prohibiting the sale and possession of
assault type
weapons and high-capacity ammunition
magazines after a man identified as omar
mateen kills 49 people in orlando
florida gay nightclub on june 12th using
an ar-15 semi-automatic rifle and a call
to 9-1-1 he made during the attack
mateen told the police he had pledged
his allegiance to the radical islamic
terrorist group isis october 1st 2017
barely over a year after the orlando
shooting a man identified as stephen
craig paddock opens fire on an outdoor
music festival in las vegas shooting
from the 32nd floor of the mandalay bay
hotel paddock kills at least 59 people
and wounds more than 500 others august
12 2019 president trump voiced the
support for the red flag gun
confiscation laws we must make sure that
those judged to pose a grave risk to
public safety do not have access to
firearms and that if they do those
firearms can be taken through rapid due
process he said so barack obama is
saying you ought to have permission to
take guns and wildlife and trump is
saying due to red flag laws we should
confiscate shouldn't be the other way
around it's kind of interesting right
how you're going through this reading
history you're realizing maybe both
sides can reason
if they're willing to get into a room
and talk so now let's look at let's look
at what states have the most gun owners
i'll give you top five on each side
on
the lease gun owners number one is
jersey 14.7 percent then it's
massachusetts rhode island hawaiian new
york matter of fact i'll give you five
more connecticut illinois california
maryland delaware is in the top 10 least
gun-owning states with florida being at
number 11. and the most gun ownership in
america number one is montana then it's
wyoming alaska idaho west virginia at
the fifth spot so listen either these
stats are going to get you to say i want
to move to montana maybe wyoming maybe
i'll go to florida number 11. or you're
going to say oh i don't want i don't
want to be in a place where people own
guns maybe go to california maybe go to
new york maybe go to hawaii maybe go to
jersey number one compete for least
amount of people owning guns but the
choice is yours depending on which side
you lean however here's some stats with
all the talks about gun control coming
up 2020 was the record-breaking year for
the most background checks ever done in
the history of america and 2021 was the
second highest year in the most
background checks ever done in america
so a lot of these stats maybe just stats
i've been giving you but this next stat
could be the one that's gonna get you
thinking when i watch the movie
moneyball
with the story of brad pitt that he's
playing the story of billy bean i
brought billy bean to three events
because the way they broke down what the
most important statement baseball was
was on base percentage not home runs not
hits not doubles not triples not
pitching on base percentage and they
built this team that broke the record
they won 21 games in a row nobody could
believe oakland smallest budget in the
end and the mlb was beating the yankees
so
you ready for the stat here's what it
looks like according to the crime
prevention research center
free zones
areas where guns are prohibited
have been the target of 94
of all mass shootings let me say this
one more time
areas
where guns are prohibited 94
of all mass shootings have been in those
areas which means only six percent
have been in areas that are not
prohibited where somebody can have a
license to carry the criminals don't
want to go shooting there because they
know somebody has a gun but in areas
where people don't have guns are like
i'm going to feel more confident go to
this area 94
the staggering number is why such
designated areas are referred to as soft
targets meaning unprotected and
vulnerable ninety-four percent of
shootings has happened in a gun-free
zone could that 94 change if those areas
became an area where people can have a
license to carry with the criminal and
the shooter say i'm going to be thinking
twice before i go into this movie
theater or this church or school because
somebody may be caring i'm not going to
mess around maybe maybe not i think the
answer is yes and by the way do you hear
when they say mass shooting mass
shooting
293 mass shooting in 2022 as of june
28th and we're like oh my gosh
so many mass shootings what's going on
here i remember the numbers being this
big but they don't tell you the
definition mass shooting is when four or
more people got shot in one incident but
nobody died
died
a mass murderer
is when four or more people died in a
shooting okay so which number is more
scary 293 or the number for mass murder
in 2022 as of june 28
is 14.
now 14 is a big number period one is too
many numbers that we have but one scares
people 14 doesn't scare you if we say
293 like that's so many of them but 14
that's not marketing when they talk
about numbers right having said let's
take a look at what's in this bipartisan
safer community act so here's what's in
the bill number one 750 million dollars
to help states implement and run crisis
intervention programs this money can be
used to implement and manage red flag
programs which are aimed at keeping guns
out of the hands of those who pose a
threat to themselves or others number
two this legislation closes a year's old
loophole in domestic violence law that
barred individuals who had been
convicted of domestic violence crimes
against spouses or partners with whom
they share children or cohabitated with
from having guns all statues didn't
include intimate partners who may not
live together be married or share
children the new bill would bar anyone
who is convicted of a domestic violence
crime against someone they have a
continuing serious relationship of a
romantic or intimate nature
with from having a gun number three
requires more gun sellers to register as
federally licensed firearm dealers
number four more thorough reviews of
people ages 18 to 21 who want to buy
guns the bill encourages states to
include juvenile records in the national
instant crime background check system
with grants as well as implement a new
protocol for checking those records
number five
creates new federal statutes against gun
trafficking and straw trafficking the
legislation makes it easier to go after
those who are buying guns
for individuals who are not allowed to
purchase weapons on their own and last
but not least number six increases
funding for mental health programs and
school security the money is directed to
a series of programs many of which
already exist but would be funded more
robustly under the new law
so which one of these six would have
prevented yuvaldi from happening 750
million dollars to implement a run
prevent
interruption programs no closing the
so-called boyfriend no requires more gun
sellers no number five more thorough
reviews of those ages 20 18 to 21
juvenile record i don't think he had it
number five creates new federal statues
against gun trafficking nope increases
funding for mental health how maybe not
so again
these are good it's some progress but
would it have prevented
many of these mass murders from
happening so look at this point you can
say you're forward you're not four but
let me give you an idea what markers
we're really dealing with when it comes
down to gun control one is age
two is type of weapon three is training
four is background checks
five is medical history what kind of
prescription you're taking six is amount
of ammunition you can walk away with
type of ammunition you can get your
upbringing and socioeconomic status
meaning did you were you raised with a
father parents together married all that
stuff next one is police training
because yuvaldi could have been
prevented due to what the cops would
have done that was on them a little bit
on what they did and last but not least
length of time it takes to walk away and
take ownership of your weapon so let's
go through these 18 to 21
i think i'm good with 18 i'm good with
21 that's something that we can hash it
out and debate next one type of weapon
semi-automatic weapon you got you know
m16s you got the rifles you got guns if
you were to actually break down what
percentage of the shootings were done by
semi-automatic weapons or rifles
the number one weapon that they use when
they're doing any kind of shootings is a
basic pistol that they use okay we got
three more left one of them is police
training those police who didn't go in
to do their jobs and their chapter was
telling them not to go and the captain
should be fired or the people that
didn't go in there should be some kind
of accountability to be in there i'm not
talking about prison time but either
this is not a job for you because i
remember when we're in the military
there was an exercise we did where we
had to low crawl and we're going through
and they're shooting it's late at night
and it's scary some guys couldn't handle
it they stood up
that's a perfect opportunity to tell
these guys military is not for you go
home some people are cops shouldn't be
cops some people are teachers shouldn't
be teachers there's many opportunities
when you notice you're just not meant to
be a teacher you don't have the patience
for kids you need to go find a different
job you're not meant to be a cop you
can't handle this kind of pressure go to
a different job now next item
how long before i take the gun with me
now think about this here
tell me any reason
why a person ought to be able to go to a
store
buy a gun who's never owned a gun before
and walk out 5 10 15 20 minutes later
give me any reason that we're gonna need
it minus there's a war taking place and
the government want us to be armed let's
just say if that's the case don't you
think the government would announce and
say effective today men can go get guns
and all that let's just say that ugly
situation takes place aside from that
why does a person need to get the gun
right now go use it can you wait a week
have you ever been upset at somebody and
a week later you got over it have you
ever gone to an ugly argument with an ex
of yours and a day two days three weeks
later a week later you were over it so
if you can wait a week to get calm after
deciding to do something bad maybe we
give it a week before you can walk away
with your gun what's wrong with that
maybe we make it two weeks so that's a
discussion that can be had but you know
which one i think matters the most the
last one here here's what it is social
economic status father figure in your
life the more stability the better the
economy is the more money people make
the less situations to want to be
desperate to do something bad
keeping the family nucleus together is
important we keep not giving enough
credence to this this matters when i'm
at home and my kids are running around
doing what they're doing my
mother-in-law can say whatever she wants
to say my nanny my wife can say whatever
they say and then when i come in things
change very quickly fathers have a
certain influence over their kids
that maybe mothers don't have especially
when it comes down to boys
we need to
go back to recognizing the right values
and principles maybe some of the values
and principles we learned from our
grandparents maybe they're right
maybe we need to go talk about some of
that stuff maybe we need to say hey
whatever denomination you are whatever
church you are whatever faith you are
practice it take your kids to church
take them to maybe your school as a
public school and you're not necessarily
able to
put your kids in an environment to learn
some conservative values i don't care if
you're a christian catholic
seventh-day you're you're whatever
whatever juda whatever you practice
actually put your kids in those types of
environments because many instances in
those environments somebody can come
across and play the role of a father
figure to challenge uplift to say
there's hope good things can happen in
life as well i think that plays a very
very important role
[Applause]
so while we were editing this video two
other tragic events took place having to
do with gun violence one of them was in
highland park a suburb of chicago the
other one was in japan the one in
chicago was by a robert e cremo who
decided to open fire at a fourth of july
parade in highland park seven people
died 38 people were wounded the rifle
was legally purchased and robert cremo
checked us out had been visited by the
police on two separate occasions in 2019
after he threatened to kill everyone and
nothing happened okay and keep this in
mind this happened in chicago which has
some of the strictest gun laws and on
top of that the strictest gun laws also
has the most homicides in america
chicago is number one second place is
not even close so it happened in that
city with the strictest gun laws and the
other tragic event was in japan
the former prime minister
shinzo abe was shot and killed during a
campaign event on july 8th the attack
has completely shocked the country where
gun violence is virtually non-existent
handguns are banned in the country and
people must undergo extensive tests
training and background checks to obtain
and keep shotguns and air rifles
and you ready for the craziest part of
the story
the the shooter
got the weapon not from a store not
illegally in the streets
it was a crude
homemade
he made it the shotgun he used
to kill the former prime minister which
has never happened i mean it's it's
tough it's an event that japan is not
accustomed to something like this it'll
be interesting to see how they come up
with new policies and just think about
you're the next prime minister running
you're on stage campaigning
and what are you thinking about you
could be the next person it can really
mess with emotion so again these are two
separate events in two different
locations and two different countries
where different gun laws are but the
results are both tragic
anyways having said that i want to hear
hear your thoughts what do you think is
the solution if you're going to comment
below with your emotions do it totally
fine i disagree i do this i'm totally
fine with that but what i'm more
interested in is pat you miss this one
area what if we did this i am only
looking for solutions from reasonable
people if you got them comment below
having said that if you want today's
notes in a pdf click over here to get
the pdf and if you want to watch another
interview in regards to this topic i did
with colin noor click here to watch that
interview take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]